(bright instrumental music)
- [Narrator] These ruins lie deep
in the jungle; and if you look closely,
you'll see thousands of hieroglyphics,
which tell the ancient
story of the Mayan empire.
(bright instrumental music)
Tikal National Park can be found
in Northern Guatemala's Petén Basin.
The park is a UNESCO
World Heritage Site due
to its extraordinary wildlife
and cultural significance.
Situated on over 142,000 acres of jungle
it is the home to amazing biodiversity.
The ancient site includes palaces,
temples, and even courts for games.
All the remnants of a
civilization that thrived
from 600 BCE
to 900 CE.
The complex at Tikal was formerly
a center of Mayan culture.
At its height, Tikal traded with cities
in Mexico, Honduras, and Belize.
The structures here are some
of the most important
archeological sites left
by the Mayans and a trip to Tikal
is not only a journey
of extraordinary beauty
but a window into the past.
(bright instrumental music)